good afternoon and welcome to this joint
standards committee on thursday 16th of
june 2022
my name is councillor fleming and i am
the chairman of this committee
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate that you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones
therefore can i ask that when invited to
speak remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
before we move on
i would like to thank councillor
bassinger who unfortunately is not here
for his excellent chairmanship of this
committee over the last 18 months
steering us through some very difficult
meetings
tara may i have apologies please
yes
[Music]
thank you tara
i turn to the minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 8th of february 2022
and found on pages three to twenty
twenty two twenty two are approved as a
true and accurate record i so move do i
have a seconder for that motion
thank you
councillor nung
do we agree those by ascent members
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or non-binary
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members
members are also reminded that they are
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the needs need a rise throughout
the meeting
in the interests of openness and
transparency i would like to point out
at this point that most of the members
of this committee sat on either the
southeast planning committee or the
district planning committee referred to
an in agenda item 15
any declarations members to make
councillor helm
noted thank you councillor helm anybody
else
thank you
okay we move on to agenda item five
found on pages 23 to 40 reports on the
motion of councillor fluker regarding
the planning decision on land south of
charwood and east of orchard stoney
hills burnham on crouch
the purpose of the report is to assist
the committee to make a recommendation
to council on any action that should be
taken on councillor fluker's motion
members on page 23 we have been given
four alternative recommendations to
choose to make to the council i'm going
to shortly ask councillor quelch to
present his report
not cancel the question
i've promoted him or maybe not or maybe
not um
so and then i'm going to call on
councillor fluker to speak to his motion
and then i'm going to turn to mr
mitchell our independent person to
comment
then finally i'll turn to councillor
helm who seconded the motion to speak
and then we can ask mr quelch any
questions and then discuss and then
finally i will then turn to the
recommendations
take each one as they're listed
call for a second and then we can vote
thank you
councillor swain um yeah it's just a
matter of um
procedure
um the motion was
moved and debated at um council and
remitted to us
um is it right that we simply go through
another
rehearsal of the motion and debate or
are we not just considering the content
of the motion from the point of view of
jsc's
responsibilities we're cons well i'll
defer to mr quelch in a minute from my
point of view as the chair we're
considering
the content we're giving councillor
fluker the opportunity to speak to his
motion
um
i'll just turn to council culture and
then i'll go to mr crush and then i'll
go to councillor none
thanks thanks sir chairman um
yes i always forget that sorry
um
yeah uh thank you very much chairman uh
the
this motion of counselor fluke was
automatically referred without debate in
fact
to jsc to the joint standards committee
because it's within its remit
and the only role of jsc today
is to make a recommendation to council
so once that recommendation is made that
will then go back to full council and
with that recommendation there will be a
debate on council of lucas motion
so in short
yes you can debate the motion fully
because
council is looking for your guidance
as to how to deal with this motion
counselor when are you satisfied with
that i think
yes
thank you um councillor nunn well mr
quelch has covered it actually chairman
but i mean i don't recall us debating it
at all at full council i recall it um
that it was referred to this committee
thank you
i'll i turn now to councillor fluka um
sorry to cut mr help quelch um and then
i'll go to councillor plucker thank you
ah yes yes sir yeah i i need to do that
as well thank you i forget to put put it
on and i forget to turn it off i'm sorry
um
yeah thank you very much um chairman
you've got my report there um my
assessment of reading the
decision letter in relation to cost that
you will see there are two appendices
there's the decision letter relating to
the decision
on the appeal
which doesn't deal with issues of
whether the council was predetermined or
unreasonable conduct and then you have a
second letter which specifically deals
with the application by the appellate
for their costs
inspectors will only agree
us award against the local authority
if there has been some
there has been unreasonable conduct
by the council
or some um procedural defect that the
inspector
is of the view merits across award
against the council
putting the the appellant to unnecessary
expense so those are really the two
broad categories
and the inspector in his cost letter you
will see came down on the side that the
council
was unreasonable
in failing to substantiate the two
reasons it put forward for refusing the
application
one reason was to deal with design and
the other was
outlook and the inspector formed the
view that the council had failed to
substantiate in any way
those
two reasons that it had put forward the
inspector wasn't saying because i
disagree with you and the reasons you
put forward i'm awarding costs no that
wasn't his decision his decision was
because you haven't put forward evidence
to substantiate those two reasons two
reasons that's unreasonable conduct
so it is it is it is unusual for
inspectors to award costs members need
to know that
it is the exception rather than the rule
and so
um
the unreasonable conduct
of the council he felt was such
and a cost award should be made
now in the motion of councillor flugrad
also mentions predetermination i am
totally convinced
that the inspector did not make a
decision on pre-determination the only
reason pre-determination is included in
his cost letter is because the applicant
in his case to try and persuade the
inspector to make a cost award mentioned
predetermination and as is customary for
all judges
and planning inspectors because they're
all aware of appeals that can be made
they generally rehearse the main points
of someone's application
to show that they've understood what
they're saying and the nature of their
application so the only reason the
inspector
mentioned pre-determination was to
rehearse
the argument of the applicant but as you
read the letter
if you go to the letter itself you'll
see
at the top
i'm just going to turn to it myself at
page
page
37
you'll see
first paragraph that is the award the
application for an award of course is
allowed in the term set out below and
then he gives his reason for making that
award
and the award is
that
um
unreasonable behavior
um he then goes on to explain why he
does that and he deals with the
subheading the application that's the
application by the appellant for costs
and in that he rehearses the
pre-determination argument
and then right at the end
he has conclusions
as will be seen from my decision
decision issued on this case i've
decided in favor of the appellant on the
substantive question of whether the
proposed development should be permitted
um
as will be seen for my decision on the
issue of design energy there was no
specific criticism by the council for my
part i considered that the proposed
dwelling relates well to the character
etc etc
and then he says
on the second point if my
sorry my computer will work yeah
on the second issue the council has not
explained how the alleged loss of
outlook
would result from the appeal proposal
um uh i concluded paragraph 12 that both
refusal reasons in the in the case had
not been substantiated and did not form
any justification for the refusal of
panic mission therefore i thought i find
therefore or i therefore find that the
unreasonable behavior resulting in a in
unnecessary or wasted expense as
described in the ppg has been
demonstrated and that a full award of
costs is justified so it's quite clear
just following the structure of his
letter
that he is only making his decision on
unreasonable conduct not
predetermination so my advice to the
committee would be in dealing with
councillor fluker's motion
um
about two things going back to the
inspector and asking for who would the
councillors
um that were responsible for this
and then an external investigation you
should only be looking at the issue of
unreasonable conduct because that was
the only basis on which the inspector
made the decision
in relation to
my report going back
finally
you'll see i've given you alternatives
so um
there's four alternatives there and i'm
obviously not giving you my view because
that's the matter for you to decide you
can go from um that an external
investigation ought to take place
on the planning application only or you
could say yes there should be an
external investigation but it should be
wider is there a systemic problem with
the council's decision making by members
or
no no external investigation but
the council needs to be reminded of its
responsibilities to to make decisions
based on evidence and not because they
personally don't like it i mean that
if that's what members are doing just
relying on their personal
preferences then that obviously is
defective decision making
or that the council simply rejects the
need for an external investigation that
it would be pointless members
dealing with the first part of
councillor um
lucas motion about going to the
inspector and asking for who were the
members because there is no
predetermination
and on the issue of
unreasonable conduct
the inspector will be making this
decision collectively not based on
individual counsellors
input
so there'll be no point going back to
the inspectorate on that at all
thank you mr quelch i'll turn to
uh councillor fluker
you have five minutes to speak to your
motion thank you yeah thank you very
much gentlemen and uh yeah i i agree
with uh as usual most of what mr quelch
has said um chairman and members for the
benefit of public interest can i confirm
that following the member's overturn of
the officer's recommendation to approve
this plan in application and the subs uh
the subsequent successful appeal
um to the planning especially the costs
award against the council has now been
agreed and paid to the appellant um
i shall now turn to the cost decision
uh at appendix three
whilst i understand paragraph three
headed the application contains the
comments raised by the appellants
they have nevertheless been considered
by the plan inspectorate against written
evidence submitted by the opponent and
have been included in the report now i
know that they've been tested but i do
recognize the argument of rehearsal that
mr quelch has
mentioned and they were tested and
that's why they were included
i accept that the comments are not those
that inspect but nevertheless with the
benefit of the appellant statements the
inspector did choose to include the
statements in this decision notice um
the other the other issue that i'm
concerned about and it's more of a
global one is paragraph nine and the
rebuttal
ordinarily this is where the act the the
council acting as the lpa would
challenge the appendant statements it
can be seen from the the decision notice
that the council did not raise any
objections to any of the appoints
referred to in the appellant statement
which is summarized in paragraph three
so the council's read paragraph one
student's additional documents which are
referred to later and has chosen not to
make a rebuttal which is absolutely
extraordinary in my mind
so in summit the council chose not to
defend the appeal
um
the appellant statement uh refers to
substantive unreasonable behavior and
predetermination by elected members of
the council
um the plan inspector in his conclusion
says that both reasons these were the
reasons for refusing the application in
this case have not been substantiated
and did not form any justification for
the refusal and i think that mr quelshan
quelch has uh has said that the motion
before you asks that the principal issue
of substantive unreasonable behavior and
predetermination is evidenced by the
inspector
the purpose being
is to ask the inspector the replete to
release the appellant written statements
um i can say to the committee that i've
since
uh contacted pins
and i can confirm i have now had sites
of those documents which i'm more than
happy to share
with this committee with the permission
of mr quelch
given the content of the correspondence
between the appellant's lawyer and
officers from malden district council
which again i can provide both the
lawyers letters and the response from
this council
i requested
an independent
person is is appointed to look at this
on solely on the grounds of impartiality
because you you have offices from this
council and the monitoring officer
chairman if if this committee were
minded to positively address the motion
i would ask that the following points
are considered
why the council did not contend the
appeal which i think is very very
important
that the appellant's application notice
notice for costs is considered because
that has not been annexed to these
documents and i think it should have
been that the correspondence from the
appellant addressed morton district
council dated the 18th of february
is considered and particularly so with
regards to the evidence based on
allegations of pre-determination and the
conduct of the southeastern area
planning committee meeting that the
correspondence from hixson hill
llp solicitors addressed to mdc dated
the 12th of march is considered and in
particular the evidence-based
allegations that some members were
predetermined resulting in the decision
of the committee being unlawful and
finally chairman on this point that the
written response to hixson hill letter
from morton district council dated 26th
of march is considered particularly so
with regards officers comments
concerning the pre-determination of
members now again chairman i have a copy
of that letter and and i i i can't
circulate it to members without the
permission of the managing officer um
chairman i i'll talk briefly to the
recommendations um chairman as a
preamble firstly i remind members of the
public that all elected members have
received compulsory planning training
including on pre-determination
for the benefit of public interest i
confirm that the costs agreed and
incurred in the last year
following successful appeals against
members decision is now in excess of a
quarter of a million pounds and that the
sum
is met in its entirety by local
council
taxpayers their money not ours
i would also point out that the council
in its capacity of the lpas received
adverse negative publicity with regards
to lost appeals following members
overturns
and the pub that publicity has almost
certainly affected our ability to
recruit into vacant posts those are not
my words they are a member of a senior
member of the planning department
members now have the chance chairman
to demonstrate to the public and
officers that they are prepared to
scrutinize themselves for the long-term
betterment of this council and
particularly when it is acting as a
local planning authority with regards to
the recommendations specifically
chairman i would propose that the
recommendation to is agreed on the
grounds that
recommendation one is insular to the
application only and that due to public
interest openness and transparency and
the furtherance of building better
officer and public confidence in member
decision making at planning committees
and to prevent allegations of
impropriety
recommendations three
and four
are discounted chairman i must be very
close to five minutes
uh and if i'm not you're actually over
oh am i well i'm very quick i'm being
indulgent
thank you councillor fluke up before
i turn to mr mitchell tara can i just uh
check that you have um the detail of
councillor fluka's opening remarks
regarding the correspondence and the
date
thank you um and then i'm just going to
turn quickly to mr quelch to um answer
councillor lucas question as to whether
it would be
i'm searching for the word here
appropriate advisable uh to
uh take receipt of the paperwork that mr
councillor fluke is referring to thank
you and if it helps you i'm not actually
in a position to actually circulate it
right now i do have a hard copy but i
don't but i just wanted to make it
absolutely clear that these this
correspondence is in existence and i
really do think it should be shared with
members thank you
yes
chairman there's two issues really here
the first is i haven't seen the
documentation so i don't know what it
says
um
i didn't know there was any
documentation that council of luca had
had found or been sent so i haven't seen
it
and um secondly
um
i think the committee needs to be
needs to be aware that you're not
actually carrying out the external
you're not carrying out the
investigation the motion is whether an
investigation should be carried out
so all you're doing is understanding the
issues and saying
um from what we've heard from what we've
read because all you really need to see
is the inspector's decision does the
inspectors
decision letter on the application
and then
especially the cost letter cause you
sufficient concern
to make you think this should be
investigated
you might you may have no idea what the
result of that investigation would be
but i think that's the issue for the
committee so
there is a danger that you start to go
into
the
the details that any external
investigator would look at
um
and so there's that issue how far do you
go i would i would advise that you've
got the inspectors decision letter
and he has to explain and he has
explained in full why he's reached the
decision he has on costs and you need to
ask yourselves based on that official
document
and those reasons given is there grounds
for an external investigation and if so
how wide
i i that's how personally i think the
issue so i think the issue of documents
is
could complicate matters for you in the
sense that you start to investigate it
too much
thank you mr quelch i'm going to just uh
park that for the time being i'm going
to turn to mr mitchell and then i will
go to
councillor hell thank you
thank you chairman
good afternoon members
um
actually just preamble i've looked
through this i've looked at the um
the submitted documents that came with
the appeal that's on the council's
website and i've read the
subsequent correspondence with the
inspector and on the narrow point of
whether there was the inspector took
into account pre-determination
uh in making his costs award i would say
that he didn't i would agree with mr
quartz on that it was limited to the
council's unreasonable behavior
regarding the um
the reasons for refusal
and he found against the council on both
the appeal and for the application for
costs on that
i think the the the other point
councillor
luca mentioned regarding um
the council's evidence
is another matter it's good practice in
planning appeals by written
representation which was to just
effectively
attach the officer's report the minute
of the meeting
and
that then stands as the council's
evidence and that's
what happened here
the difficulty here was there was a
council decision that was contrary to
the recommendation
uh
of the officers so all these but no
evidence was put forward to support that
recommendation
i don't think it was deliberately done
like that the practice was just to send
the minute
but in doing that of course the
inspector only had in front of him the
appellants statement
and i think the appendices that your
counselor fluker refers to are actually
on the council's website already i think
they're already there
um
so whether that was an oversight but
certainly had the council addressed
those points
um
his decision letter would look very
different because it would say he would
have said um
uh when it came to a rebuttal the
council would be able to say no there
was no predetermination here and you'd
have had a very different outcome from
that
so
you know rather than
a wholesale re-examination this could
just be a small case of having to look
at
best practice in the very unusual event
firstly of a written representations and
a member overturned secondly it is
extremely unusual to have an application
for costs
uh with a written representations
planning appeal
and that works both ways the council can
also apply for costs in these
circumstances so
that was where i would leave it at the
moment is obviously up to members to
determine where they take this
but it would seem to me that as a
one-off this is a straightforward
instance that um
the the inspector had the benefit
only of one side of the argument if you
like he had the officers report
which was clearly
leading towards a recommendation of
approval
and it was he obviously had the evidence
of the plans and his own decision-making
capabilities that he saw when he went to
the site visit and looked at the
relationship with the adjoining
properties so he would have had the
opportunity to make his own mind up as
well so he could take that
it's a perfectly reasonable decision
in the light of the evidence available
that's it so sorry if it's a bit longer
than i was anticipating but there we go
thank you chairman
thank you mr mitchell i'll turn to
councillor helm uh who seconded the
motion to speak to the motion thank you
thank you very much madam chairman
it's nice to be invited to speak to the
motion
um i agree with everything that
councillor fleurger has said
and there was obviously a
a problem at southeast because it had to
be referred to
the main council
therefore i agree with councillor fluka
that this should be investigated further
because there's more reasons behind all
this and as we're talking about public
money that's been spent here we need to
have the bones of it thank you
thank you councillor helm
okay members over to you to ask any
questions of mr quelch and to discuss
what we've heard already thank you
councillor nunn
um well i've read and re-read mr
quelcher's report and
i do recall the case
as i sat on the full council planning
committee that
it was referred to
i felt myself a slight disadvantage i
thought i knew the case then i felt i
was at a slight disadvantage when
councilor fluker introduced his
additional evidence which i hadn't seen
but i think what was really helpful is
the comments from
mr quelch that we should really just
focus entirely on
um the inspectors appeal uh decision and
the decision for costs
uh and you know i just wonder whether we
can just set aside for one moment the
additional correspondence that
councillor fluker has mentioned
councillor helm as a committee member
thank you
madam chairman um should there not be
full discussion from
well everybody participating before we
move to any recommendation
i agree councillor swain so who would
like to go next at councillor stevens
thank you chair i'd really like to
understand what we would get out of an
external investigation which is going to
add to the costs that the local
residents would have to um foot
that we wouldn't be able to achieve
ourselves because i do feel it's a
little like the old quality inspections
of the 70s and 80s that the harder you
look the more you'll find something that
might or might not have been done
slightly differently
and actually you're better off putting
your energies into future process and
future improvements and not keep looking
back
at
old ground that we've all gone over
i'd i don't see what that advantage
would be perhaps somebody could explain
that to me please thank you
thank you councillor stevens
mr quelch do you want to comment on
puppet
very very difficult for me to comment um
um
very difficult for me to comment
obviously i think that's a matter for
member decision making whether they
think that there's any value in that
than me to comment on that
i can't say yay or nay whether there
would be a benefit or not i think that's
that's your territory members
so sorry just to clarify i don't know
that i was particularly asking for mr
quelch to answer to see why you can't i
think that's something i'm throwing open
to the floor does anybody see an
advantage of doing that because i can't
see it thank you thank you councillor
stephen i'll go to councillor thompson
thank you kevin
um
to try and answer council stevens
questions from you chairman i
i'm not sure that
there is this all depends
so far i haven't seen any substantive
evidence not having seen council of
lucas documents and in fact not knowing
what they are what they are or having
any idea what the content is i do
remember the meeting about the
discussion about shall we take it to
district or not which was a pnc meeting
i'm not sure at this stage what there is
to discover we could go looking for
predetermination or not but that wasn't
the reason the application that the
appeal was lost in the end by us i mean
for the reason it was granted
i don't see this point what there is to
be gained but the fact is members have
training
over and over again and i mean some of
us for many years some of us for far
fewer years
um that this is a regulatory matter
planning much the same as licensing
and our opinions are nothing to do with
it
in point of fact though i regret it in
many ways our residents opinions are
nothing to do with it
it is a matter of policies being set
both nationally and locally and once
they are
our job is to follow them and
while anyone is entitled to give
different weight to different policies
from an officer's report saying i mean
i've often heard it said you put 10
planners in a room you might come up
with 11
opinions not unlike lawyers i'm told
but the fact is it's a question of
balancing policy
and coming up
with what hope is the right answer as
far as the unreasonable behavior goes
i mean this is not unreasonable in the
sense that we were for a while they're
all too too often
of course to become accustomed to i mean
this is the case of giving reasons for
refusal that
were not substantiated now the officers
are terribly limited on what help they
can give us
um
it's
rather planning offices i mean it's
rather easier for them when
we're trying to overturn for a refusal
but you know
with the tilted balance we have to
demonstrate that
significant harm for my i have a problem
with first defined significant but
you have to make the case for
significant harm if you're going to
refuse an application in the current
circumstances
evidently the inspector thinks we didn't
it's his view it's the one that counts
we can think what we like but you know
in the end it's not a matter of opinion
it's a matter of regulation thank you
chad
thank you councillor thompson
councillor bill did you want to go next
thank you
thank you councillor bill i will go to
councillor swain next please
uh thank you madam chairman i'm picking
up just a couple of points of revision
in the last few minutes
um and referring perhaps immediately to
what councillor bill has um
mentioned um
examination generally of decisions that
have been made by planning
uh
is not is a very large job and it would
be extremely expensive if done
externally
but we have a pg a committee and we have
overview and scrutiny who
really should be um taking up this issue
of um appeals overturns who's
overturning whom
and this is not just a question of
occasionally
members overturning a decision like this
but
it runs all the way through the planning
planning process
so in fact i have uh tried to initiate
this at the moment with overview and
scrutiny to look more closely at the
record on appeals overturns and so on
and which ones have been overturned and
the reasons
the reasons given for overturning all
the reasons um that were put forward for
proposing
um because in a lot of planning issues
um the
determinants this includes particularly
as an officer level are to a large
extent judgmental
and subjective
and therefore
amenable to a different view
the other point was about all this
background material that counselor fluke
has alluded to
which obviously is largely
from the one aggrieved party
um or on that on that party's behalf and
i think the fact that this was
and dealt with it by written
representations is a problem in itself
and i think the fact that the weight of
the
um
material is as we say from the
um appellant
um has colored the um
the view and the language of the
planning inspector as shown in that um
paragraph three on page 37 which i think
some of it is rather um exceptionable
we do have the two issues here about the
cost award and um this
aspersions we say of um predetermination
by
a
certain unnamed
councillor and by implication a certain
group of councillors which he refers to
as a cohort in in that paragraph fee
um
the the the numbers are quite are
relevant
the
um
the motion to refuse was part was passed
by
15 to 6
and then the the reason given for
refusal was passed by 16 to four
um and that was actually on a member's
proposal member for haybridge not from
the southeast committee at all
um
so
there's quite a significant um
majority i i have to um say at this
point that i was one of the few who
actually supported the officer's
recommendation in the first place
now as to the question of the awards um
i can fully accept what the planning
expect inspector says about the reasons
and the
poor reasons given by council by the
district planning committee and
the unjustifiable decisions and and
therefore
um the award of costs against the um
the council
i mean as i think uh council thompson's
alluded um members do have to take a
view um
on um um particular issues which it does
reflect how
how people feel about it
while still of course having regards the
fact that they are operating under
planning guidance and planning law
and this is where um
things have gone wrong in this answer in
other cases too
but
making up a re-hit a re-hearing or
offering a hearing and recharging a
decision at district level
because of legal guidance isn't
novel it does happen um this is not a
unique case in that case and i don't
think um
personally i don't think that that
background idea of legal action
was the primary mover for re-hearing it
was the fact that the
the um
original
um
arguments against the application were
rather weak
so i do think we need to have a thorough
review of the
of planning decision making and the
outcome um but this should be done
internally by pgna
and or overview and scrutiny
now turning to that
rather odd paragraph three um on page
37.
um it does seem to have been influenced
by the
the allegations or the aspersions
suggestions are of of the agree of an
agreed party
and done through written representations
um
particularly
when this is where the numbers come in
the reference to this unnamed counselor
and his cohort
of um uh of supporters i suppose
um presumably who are also
deemed to be partly pre-determined the
fact is that the motions that district
planning were overwhelmingly
um
moved past by
um members who are not anything to do
with halsey's south seas planning
um so i think that completely waters
down any argument that predetermination
has influenced the
the vote um the final vote at district
level
um and i think uh the planning inspector
has slightly gone beyond his remit in
to say repeating what is little more
than hearsay
second-hand information
in his his report
and while that the
decision on costs can be injustified
entirely on
poor planning decisions
um i do wonder whether he
that the
material in the written representations
from the
appellant um prejudiced him slightly
against the the council
in um coming to his um
opinions
um so um
in view of what i've just said it seems
to me that the obvious
option
of recommendation is number three um
that uh mr quelch has formulated
in other words
we do not need an external investigation
of planning procedures and planning
decisions we should be capable of doing
that ourselves
and
reinforce the idea that the notion that
the wild members can represent
local attitudes and um
make sure that local feelings are fully
represented they still have to be guided
by
the planning guidance planning law
thank you councillor swain i'll turn to
councillor thompson um thank you
chairman well if that's a proposal from
council swain i'm seconding it so just
it sounded like one to me but he didn't
actually say
if he would care to confirm
then i think that's the general idea i
would tend to say to ons
thank you councillor thompson yeah i
appreciate councillor helm did make a
proposal but it didn't get as far as
being said it wasn't seconded no i you
know you're in charge i'll let you hear
about that but if captain's making a
proposal i think yes it should be looked
at
perhaps more training is in order i
don't know
um but if if training is in order we're
going to have to listen to it
actually the uh balance of voting across
the members of this committee was much
tighter than that i did check it was two
with the officer recommendation mm-hmm
five no
yes five
against and one who wasn't present
anyway so we have no idea how they would
have felt
good um councillors when you uh sorry
councillor helm you had your hand up did
you want to make further comment yes
madam chairman um i would like to
withdraw my proposal but replace another
one
that we go to over and over and over and
scrutiny to investigate this with all
the other paperwork
because that's relevant to this case why
was it the southeast decision cancelled
and why was it referred to
full planning
there's something there that needs
investigating
thank you councillor helm um before we
go any further i just want to ask
councillor fluker how he came
where are these documents from that you
have
well
as i said earlier one is from morden
district council
one is for the new penance lawyers who
off the top of my head are holmes hill
llp
now
councillor swain
spoke to the weight of those documents
what i would say is the morton district
council
when they responded to that letter they
agreed with the principal allegations
and that's why i believe
there is no rebuttal because the council
couldn't make a rebuttal because they'd
already made a decision over the
principal part of the appellant's case
this is far more complicated and trying
desperately hard mr quilt not to say too
much although i would say i do believe
those documents are in
the public domain anyway they're not
marked confidential and and i note it
wasn't addressed to you
and and and as as far as counseling
stephen's uh
yeah council stephen's comments about
what's the game well
chairman you know
director service delivery has
highlighted issues with the planning
department and chairman when i when i
spoke earlier you know i did talk about
we have a chance here to demonstrate to
the public to agents uh and officers
that members are now prepared to
scrutinize themselves for the long term
betterment of the council and let's not
forget all of these appeal decisions are
read by prospective employees when they
apply to join this council if you look
on there the first thing you see from
the institute's town planning is that
modern district council
has had the largest cost awards against
it from any council in this country for
years two hundred and thirty thousand
pounds when i say council i mean thank
you councilman thank you yeah i'll stop
there thank you
that's
can i just ask were you making an
amendment to
wreck three
so you weren't trying to tack that onto
recommendation three
no
counselor thompson
i might be able to help i mean if if if
councillor swain's motion which is now
on the table
um
if that is agreed then it goes to ons
presumably which
he didn't specify but i would have said
that was the best and maybe we need an
amendment to decide where it's going but
ons can ask for any papers it please is
an interview that he wants police
so
that pretty much encompasses councillor
helms
requests in any case i would have said
yep okay thank you councillor stevens
did you have your hand up
well i did i think we're almost there
but just to come back but i was saying
i don't see the need for an external
investigation and very much if it went
through ons or whichever committee an
internal investigation would be a matter
of public record so we can satisfy
residents requirement to see what did we
do about this and we can make large on
what are we going to do better in the
future i don't we did i didn't suggest
it should be i suggested it should be
internal i didn't suggest it should be
non-transparent and hidden thank you
thank you
councillor nunn finally um just to be
clear the chairman of the council
referred this issue to joint standards
committee
so presumably whatever we
recommend here
goes back to full council
and it will be for council to decide
whether they agree with the
recommendation to refer it to ons
yes
thank you
good right members we have a
recommendation on the table that has
been seconded recommendation proposed by
councillor swain
councillor thompson
just asked council swain for
clarification if he was specifying
overview in scrutiny
or pga i mean my thoughts would go with
overview and scrutiny but i think we
ought to know which one we're voting on
before we do
well i i think we can leave that to be
so we see automatic uh the automatic
response one would expect from council
to recommendation three and we don't
need to try and build it into this here
okay thank you
okay so counselors when you're
essentially saying that a recommendation
three you've proposed recommendation
three as it is at the moment
it's wording as it is at the moment the
counselor thompson if you second did
that
well yes but i thought councillor swain
and i was seconding was suggesting more
than that it's all very well accepting
the findings and emphasizing the need
um what councillor swain is also adding
his internal investigation
which i'm actually tempted to suggest is
recommendation four and a half or five
and not actually on the paper because mr
quelch never said we were restricted to
these
um and we can come up with
anything reasonable
we like so i i'm
i'm fully in support of what council
swain said but what he wants to call it
i'm a little at sea on
thank you councillor thompson that's why
i returned to council helm to see if he
was proposing a attack on to to uh wreck
three i'm returning to councillor swain
now
yes thank you mr chairman um
the position is um with
um i have um
which we say put forward the idea that
overview and scrutiny do look at this
area
um
but
um i'm
in consultation with mr jennings
um
i've
agreed that it would be best to see
um what pg and a
uh come up with first
um but if that is not adequate then to
get further into it with the owned uh o
and s
um so it's
as we say
it is in a way moving along that pathway
um
but if one what if uh
council wants to reinforce it in some
way then i i think that should be done
when we've sent this recommendation back
to council
okay so just for clarity councillors
when you were proposing recommendation
three i'll read it out now that the
council rejects the call for an external
investigation but accepts the findings
of the inspector and that council
emphasizes the need for more objective
and evidence-based decision making in
the future
you're moving that recommendation yes
and councillor thompson are you
seconding that
not if we're going back to just that no
i'm terribly sorry apologies to
councillor swain apologies to everyone
um i think if we're going to make
account a recommendation to council it
should be a recommendation that
is worth debating by council not
something that's vague and woolly as
let's look at it all over again at
council and begin from the beginning
which is very nearly what that is
because we've then got to go to council
and decide
what we're going to do and
my belief is that
um is that this should go to oman we
should recommend that this goes to ons
okay thank you councillor thompson so
you will make that as a proposal
eventually
okay so councillor thompson you are
withdrawing your seconding of councillor
swain's
wreck three
are there any other seconders for
councillors wayne
um can i i'm
not sure i thought council thompson was
it's her position that um
she would support
recommendation three if we're a bit more
clear about i'm suggesting it be um
looked at by overview and scrutiny
correct
okay that's fine and i
certainly agree with that good
okay
we should be specific about what we're
asking council to consider otherwise
we've spent an afternoon doing not
terribly much
good so we're amending recommendation
three so i would need a seconder for
that i would need tara to write to uh
read out uh what we're all voting for um
let me just have a word with i don't
think it's any of the numbers it's just
a recommendation a three
exactly i mean
counselor i'm at it now mr welch had to
call it something he called them one to
four but we've actually managed
councillors wayne and i to come up with
something that isn't any of those so i
don't think we really ought to be trying
to pretend it is any of those it just is
what it is
yes you're right i'm sorry
thank you um yeah um just to repeat
because as counselor stamp said the
microphone wasn't on i think there's bee
councillor
thompson
hasn't seconded
councillor sawings proposal but then has
put our own proposal forward
that says as i understand it
that
the council rejects the call for an
external investigation but accepts the
findings of the the inspector and that
an internal investigation takes place
and is referred to o and s
yes and i think that's been seconded by
councillor stevens if i'm right
great thank you mr quelch everyone happy
uh
councillor swain
yes
referring to and that is um decision the
um
more objective and evidence-based
decision-making in planning
um they've just made a blanket
appearance of the whole matter
but i think what we
is that what you
what you're suggesting
so you counsellous wayne you'd like that
wording
included
yes i mean i think it's it's recommended
the third recommendation largely but um
being more specific about getting owners
to look at it can i suggest therefore
sorry jim and that
because you've got emotion on the table
my advice is that counselor um swain is
now making an amendment
to the motion on the table with the
words
that after
an internal investigation that was
referred to ons so that
so that
more objective and evidence-based
decision-making takes place in the
future
that's just loading the investigation
isn't it
investigation needs to be an impartial
investigation and quite frankly i'm not
happy about conversations that are
taking place with mr jennings
outside of this meeting the the decision
making
or the recommendation is a democratic
process subject to joint standards
committee not an individual member of
this committee talking to a third party
noted counsellor none okay i'm going to
uh basically
move the
recommendation three that
we tack on that it goes to ons
um
targy have the wording there just for
clarity for everyone
yes and repeated by uh mr quelch
that accepts the finding of the
inspector and that the council
carries out an internal investigation
monitor though so the internal
investigation takes place and is
referred to over the extremely clear
agreed do i have a seconder for that
no
okay
councillor stevens i think we've lost
the bit about um the reason for it going
to overview the scrutiny committee
we do need the overview and scrutiny
committee to determine whether
more objective and evidence-based
decision-making needs to take place in
the future thank you
the last bit should go to pga not to
overview and scrutiny
i'll go to councillor stephens again
sorry do i need to repeat that um
i don't feel qualified to know which
committee it should go to i don't really
mind somebody else can advise on that
but i do think it's important that we
state why it's going there that it's
nothing to do with the pre-determination
allegation by the applicant or anything
to do with that we need to state that
we're trying to find out whether more
objective and evidence-based decision
making
should be
whether evidence no i'm not going to get
my words tangled up but i'm trying to
get across that we need to say why it's
going to the other committee that we're
looking to find out whether objective
and evidence based decision making is
lacking and whether it needs improving
thank you thank you councillor stephen
so basically you're agreeing with mr
councillor swain's point about adding in
the wording evidence-based
decision-making right okay
um
councillor thompson
do you want to return to your original
proposal
okay
councillor stevens were you seconding
councillor swain's amendment
i think so okay let's just take a vote
on that could it be read out again just
about how would you mind reading out
that out
yeah
so
external
yes
but it accepts the finding of the
inspector and that internal
investigation takes place
and is referred to over the executive
committee so that more objective and
evidence-based decision-making
yes
no councillor stevens is shaking her
head
so that's a no so counselor swain's
most uh
wreck is not seconded so i'll turn to
councillor thompson
is there any possibility that we can all
just withdraw our emotions and begin
again tara is that possible
the council does reject the call for an
external individual investigation but
accepts the finding of the inspector and
and the council emphasizes the need for
more objective and evidence-based
decision-making in the future
and
that to this end
the matter should be referred to
overview and
scrutiny and if necessary from the
governance
angle
to pg a since overview scrutiny it's not
strictly speaking investigatory
but it has access to the fact sorry that
isn't all meant that's posted
thank you do i have a second for that
what the last bit was but
i started to ramble i do apologize
cancer thompson do you want to repeat it
yes it was well it's the wording of
three but
with added and that the matter of
planning decision making be referred to
over review and scrutiny
okay we'll make that council's decision
okay do i have a seconder for that
councillor swain is seconding councillor
thompson's motion
okay let's put that to a vote
tara do you want to read that out just
so everyone is clear about what they're
voting
so we for proposing
that the council rejects the call for an
external investigation but it accepts
the finding of the inspector and the
council emphasizes the need for more
objective and evidence-based
decision-making in the future
and then alex was saying sorry i'm just
trying to
so then council rejects the covenant
external investigation that accepts
findings of inspection
good okay i'm going to put it to the
vote um
we've had a second i've lost the will to
live now
yes
okay i'm going to put it to the vote and
then if if that fails then we'll move on
okay good
uh okay
members if you're in agreement please
raise your hands
oh
good okay
okay those against
two against and
councillor stevens are you abstaining
yes i'll abstain okay good so
counselor number i want to make it clear
chair that i'm voting against because of
the because of the wording of the
proposal
not because of the
not because of the idea
okay noted tara could you note that in
the minutes for counsellor nun
good thank you so tara have you got that
that uh it was full for uh the
recommendation
two against and one abstention
good uh councillor stevens thank you
chair and i would just say the same that
i've abstained because i don't think the
wording is quite on the nail thank you
tara do you mind noting that in the
minutes for councillor stevens
good thank you members we got there
eventually um okay
so
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent i don't have
any uh so members thank you all for
coming today and thank you for your
contributions i now draw the meeting to
a close
at
six minutes past three
you